so a B to the X minus h plus K so let's
take a look at some examples of these
graphs so if we look at a basic graph y
equals 2 times 3 to the X okay one thing
that you'll notice is that this base if
it's greater than one okay so if the
base is greater than one it's going to
be a growth function it's going to be
growing to the right but if the base is
in between zero and one say like 1/2 or
1/3 or 1/4 it's going to be a decay
function so it's actually going to be
decreasing it's gonna be going down to
the right what you'll notice in both of
these little mini sketches I've drawn is
that the graph gets closer and closer to
the x-axis that's the horizontal
asymptote so asymptote it gets closer
and closer to doesn't cross so let's
take a look at how to graph this one
here so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna make a table we're gonna say let's
pick maybe negative 1 0 1 and 2 so 3 to
the negative 1 is 1/3 times 2 is 2/3
anything to the 0 is 1 times 2 is 2 3 to
the first is 3 itself times 2 is 6 and 3
to the second is 9 times 2 is 18 so if
we plot these points what it's going to
look like is negative 1 we're up here at
2/3 0 we're at 2 1 R at 6 okay and then
at 2 we're at 18 it starts to go right
off the graph it's growing faster and
faster okay like that so it just goes up
at a faster and faster rate it's
exponential growth now again notice that
this horizontal asymptote the x axis
which is also the line y equals 0 okay
it gets closer and closer to that line
and that's the asymptote okay now what
we're going to do is we're going to
shift this graph so let's say instead of
right graphing y equals 2 times 3 to the
X we do y equals 2 times 3 to the X
minus 2
plus one so what do you think the two
and the one do to the graph that's right
the two goes shifting right to see this
one actually has the opposite effect on
the graph from the side so negative is
actually going positive too if it was
plus it would actually go left too and
the plus one is going to shift the graph
up one which means that this asymptote
is also going to shift up one so what
we're going to do is we're going to draw
our asymptote here at y equals one every
point is going to be shifting right two
and up one so this point here is going
to be going right one two up one so now
it's there said if this point is going
to go right to up one and this point
here right to up one so you can see now
the graph looks like this okay so that's
exponential growth another question that
teachers will ask you in regards to this
type of graph is what is the domain and
what is the range so the domain you
think about what are the possible X
values and the range what are the
possible Y values so for domain I scan
from left to right because that's the
direction of the x-axis and the range I
scan from low to high that's the the
vertical direction that's what the Y
values represent so in this case you can
see the graph goes to the left and the
right forever so the domain is all real
numbers the range are going from low to
high you can see this is above one so we
could say that Y is greater than one